hey what's going on it's Bill Bird it's
time for the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday
May 1st 2023.
what's going on how are ya
good to see you good to hear from you
good to have you listening I
don't even know what I'm saying
it's Sunday night in my Boston Bruins
lost
in overtime in game seven to the Florida
Panthers
hats off to the Florida Panthers
I mean they just
I can't even say they played great they
just like played hockey I don't know
what the we were doing I really
don't know what the we were doing
do you know in that last possession
before they tied it up
in game seven
there's a Face-Off on our end there's 50
something seconds left we win the draw
two Bruins go in the corner I don't know
who the got it one Panther skates
in lifts our stick and just takes the
Puck the puck pond
hockey
they stay in our Zone
throw some garbage at the net Bing Bang
Boom it deflects off people ends
up in the back of the net that
right there
more than anything
is why we're going home and they're
moving on like I don't know what the
we were doing
and I also secondly I don't know what
the has happened to hockey I went
to
um the Edmonton Oilers versus the LA
Kings the decisive game on Saturday
night
and first of all dude you owe it to
yourself
to see Conor McDavid live
and that whole line
Leon dry Seidel and Evander K
man I mean it was
it was unbelievable
it was it was like there was there was
something Conor McDavid did in the he
had the puck down low and he just
skated like a big like
she skated around the whole
offensive zone with the puck and went
around people it it made it look it
looked like he was playing like division
whatever the they have like
division three hockey and you're just
watching this guy going that guy's
definitely going to the pros he's so
much better than all of these guys he
does that at the pro level
um
but anyways watching that game
this is a decisive game for the Kings if
they lose they're out of the playoffs
and dude no hits
and the hits that I saw were like you
know there was a couple of half-assed
hits it's just not the same game I went
to the Ottawa Maple Leafs game and
Ottawa I watched three periods I didn't
see one hit so on one side it's great
because this generation hopefully won't
have all this CTE but it's just a
completely different game
and
um
just watching the Bruins I just thought
we would just sort of skating along with
them
and a number of times like Florida was
just like Taking Liberties
once again takes me back to 2019 that
guy uh I don't know any of the
names I got two kids all right give me a
break the guy in on the uh great
player for the Panthers with the beard
just a total you know gamer
at one point there's a bunch of people
in the front of that he comes in
literally punches one of the Bruins in
the head
and then one of our guys doesn't do
anything just kind of like grabs onto
him like hey what are we doing here
dude back in the day if you did
that to a bruin that was you were
immediately in a fight somebody's gonna
beat your headed it's just it's
whatever it's a it's it is a different
game but the um
the Bruins inability
to close out that series was like
astounding
we kept scoring the back-breaking goal
and then we would just stand around
I don't know what the we were doing
so anyway
um
but on the other side like
I'm telling you man I I if I was the
Maple Leafs I would not be excited to
play these guys
they don't give a they're they're
just
they they played so great that beta dude
whatever the his name is
um watch his face uh could chuck or
whatever just stirring up like that
guy is just he's like a
cockroach you can't kill him he just
keeps coming back at you I mean that's
that's the one thing they just kept
coming like you're supposed to
in the playoffs playoffs and I'll tell
you the the one thing the number one big
difference between the regular
season in the playoffs you know what it
is blocked shots
all right nobody's trying to get in
front of a slap shot game 17 of
the Year breaking their foot of
up their leg or whatever
all right
because then you're gonna be out and no
one's going to appreciate the fact that
you block the shot they're gonna
be like oh he's injury prone and then
that's going to affect your stock nobody
does that come play off time people
are diving in front of especially
those guys who are like playing for a
contract or who are right on the bubble
so you get all these lunatics
like the sheer amount of bodies and
sticks that got in front of Bruins shots
nullified
our high-powered offense
and
you know I know that a million other
reasons why anybody on any given night
can beat somebody
you know
one game but as I was saying to like win
a series
you know if you want an example of it go
back and watch the one I just
watched where there's all these little
battles that we were just losing
and I for the life of me I don't know
why
we have a great team we have great
players and all of that but just lately
when we go into the playoffs I
don't know what happens like we just
don't we don't have a Mean Streak we
don't have anybody out there
to make people accountable
and then we're just skating around
playing this finesse game while
these guys up you know I'm not saying
like you know Florida was cheap or
anything but they were playing a tougher
game
um
I I don't get it so um I will say this
though you know
I do actually really appreciate a first
round exit if my team's gonna lose
you know I'm I am I am like win the
thing or rip the Band-Aid off so
I'm already getting over it
um
you know I'm not over it but I'm trying
to tell myself that I am I just I just
cannot believe how many times we
had that series one and we just
I'm just standing around like what how
the did that guy come in and just
just take the puck like that like
walking up to a baby
um
anyway let's move on here
congratulations to the uh Toronto Maple
Leafs Jesus Christ I mean it was just
Groundhog Day it was like hey we
were again in April here we were again
seeing Toronto Maple Leaf fans
outside of their Arena freaking
out screaming and yelling and you're
just sitting there watching it with like
one eye closed going like you know
what's gonna happen to these poor Puck
people why do they show up every
year so I'm trying to put on the game
because of cracker are about to
eliminate the Avalanche last
they saw it was two to nothing cracking
another team nobody wants to
play
um big physical team
um
but anyway uh
congratulations to the uh to the Toronto
Maple Leafs advancing for the first time
and I don't know like 17 goddamn years
and he got it I mean
I have no idea why Maple Leaf fans are
as rabid as they are it makes no sense
considering what that team does to him
every year so the fact that they finally
all of their passion was paid off this
year where they actually won a series I
was very happy for them even though a
lot of them are to Bruins fans
because they choked away it'd be like me
hating the pan I don't hate the
Panthers they beat us I like the
way the Panthers played I wish we played
that way I don't do that where uh
you know
you know I'm going to get mad at a team
because they played better than me but a
lot of them are still upset because they
they basically up a game seven
against uh against us but I will tell
you this so what is funny though
is when a team achieves what the Bruins
did in the regular season and then
chokes in the first round oh my
god do the sports fans come out
like there's you know a lot of people
listen I'm gonna give you guys a really
a a rough reality
here a lot most people lose in life
lose as far as
what is considered winning in the United
States which as far as I can tell is
having the biggest house with the most
which is a stupid way to live
all right but I mean just as far as like
going after your dreams you know
going up to the chick you have a crush
on asking her out she says yes but blub
and it all works out and she
doesn't end up the pool
guy or whatever you know most people
lose
you know it's brutal and God
doesn't care
he doesn't give a I've really come
to that realization that he just simply
doesn't give a his is hey I
made you good luck to you
[Laughter]
and I think you have a better chance of
getting somebody on the phone at
Google than you do the of having God
actually answer or hear your
prayers I think he's in a hammock
I think he lives in a giant Loft
he's one of those crazy artists that
just creates
and uh I don't know what point he's
trying to prove oh it's two to one
started the third period
um
oh this is good now I can like enjoy
this series because now I don't have to
be like sitting here as a Bruins fan
like I was before we choked it
away I was sitting here going like I
don't want to play either one of these
teams both these teams scare me
um anyway yeah I that's just how most
people lose so when people
achieve something
um
losers can't wait for you to it up
so congratulations to the bitter losers
out there
uh you will have a field day on Twitter
trying to piss off uh Bruins fans it's
like watching that
asking Giannis that on the on the
Milwaukee Bucks do you think this season
was a failure
I wish I so wish he said well if I said
yes would that make you feel better
about what you you go home to
can't say that the league finds you but
that's where it's coming from
it's where it's coming from the
the standard
that these manted jackasses in their
Hawaiian shirts that to me
that's a sports writer it always will be
I know they don't dress like that
anymore it's like
the hostage like what they're
asking these athletes to do was not
possible
all right one team wins it every year
everybody else is a failure and
and they the fact that he they that this
sports writer wants to
get this guy to admit that he failed so
he can feel better
so I loved what uh
what what uh ante tacompo however you
say his last name or is it Giannis is it
Giannis I don't know I'm a
hockey guy
I'm a dad what the am I kid I don't
even know half the guys
on my team anymore but um
like
just to be make I don't know why
the would you say that to that guy
and then everybody just chiming in going
like you know when
uh the dude said what he said to the guy
this one guy just goes Sean's like a
bunch of excuses to me
oh yeah you're not making any excuses in
your life I don't know I just
think it's like uh I think it's a real
uh
unless you're just trying to
piss people off then it's funny but like
I I don't know
if you lose you lose it sucks it
hurts no one wants to lose
but like I don't think because you lose
you have to sit there and talk to some
UNL athletic head
who never got picked in gym class and
you have to admit to him that you feel
that you're a failure
um
because I gotta be honest with you if
that guy is failing then what the
are the rest of us doing
I mean the guy was born in Greece
I don't know when he started playing
hoop but somehow made the NBA just the
fact that he did that
he's never failing
ever
what is it's like there's like two
rounds
in the NBA draft like that's a draft I
could watch the thing's over in
like a half hour and this guy's living
in Greece he makes the League
and leads the Milwaukee Bucks of
all franchises
I like both these teams I'd like to see
Sienna but I also like uh
I'd like to see the ABS where's the
Oilers
um everybody says let's go now
let's go that's that's a sports
thing now let's it go
then you gotta grab your shirt
and show the emblem let's go
go
um you know it was hilarious
was when I was at the Kings game
um in between periods
of course there's a DJ
and the kings are down this is like a
clinching game the kings are down and
this guy is like playing music
like they already won the game and he's
looking at the camera like come
on man turn up turn up and it's just
like buddy this is a uh
we're on our way out the door
here this is like a time for concern
it's time for sports fans to be talking
to each other being like hey
oh they saying it's off so it's
offsides
it's offsides
the Seattle Kraken I think they're gonna
get away with not get away with
it I think it's gonna I think it's gonna
get called by outro no goal and they're
gonna lose it in the Pepsi Center
yeah that's unfortunately this one's
going to be called back
um
so anyway
uh Here Comes no goal
uh what are you doing applying the rules
correctly although it is Colorado
I don't know how I think you know I
think some of the uh
they're pretty beta out there until you
get into the mountains right
they're just out there slapping their
wives around
you know
who are you gonna call we're up here in
the mountains
you know you want a guy doesn't hit you
you should be down there
somebody on the Prairie on the Flatlands
um
anyway
yeah so most people uh
I don't know they they they they they
they let it get to them they let life
beat them down and then it they somehow
have they they pour it in
to like Star Wars Sports
or the Marvel universe that's that's
where most men
Channel
their crushed dreams
and then they just live vicariously
through these movie franchises TV shows
or Sports now me I chose Sports
laughs
and I was watching this game seven and
my wife came downstairs and she said
bill the kids can hear you swearing all
the way upstairs
and I was like oh God am I still that
guy I'm still that guy
I mean I know I know I let the F-bomb
when we
won the draw and the guy came in and
just took the Puck away from us
I I you know what am I supposed to do at
that point
um yeah my wife came downstairs she's
like the kids are upstairs their eyes
are wide open I'm like all right because
I I usually I make an effort
to not curse and um look I'm doing the
best I can all right go yourselves
okay I'm sure you're doing something
you know
maybe you don't curse but you're too
busy playing Dungeons and Dragons is
that what you like how I up and
now I'm lashing out at you guys why
don't I what do I take you know what
bill just sounds like a lot of excuses
hey Bill do you think you failed
do you think you've failed this
afternoon when you were cursing up a
storm would you consider that a failure
uh you know what I would
I would because I don't know
I don't know anymore anyway
um I did have a great you know weekend
went up I did a little bit of stand up
tried out some new some stuff oh
look at that they got the brackets
they got the brackets and they just
showed Florida advancing
and that's not whatever now I could you
know
I could just be like a fan of hockey now
is that what I am
I mean what happened to my identity that
I was putting into these Sports I mean
literally an hour ago
I was a guy watching his team trying to
attempt to have the greatest season
since the 77 Montreal Canadiens
and now I'm just a guy who's just a fan
of hockey who just is
kind of rooting for more games
like right now I it's it's it's
two to one I want the Avalanche to tie
it up and then I wanted to go into
overtime because
I've been exposed I don't really have
anything to do outside of this
[Laughter]
or possibly better is now now
that my team lost
they lose on the last day of the month
and uh
now I do my 10-day sabbatical
from everything
so now I'm gonna have to sit here in the
Dr and dry dock
no cigars
I don't really smoke too much anymore
anyway but no cigars which I'm really at
least I did that
I'm telling you man
if you want to quit smoking cigars get
them out of your house or your
apartment
empty a humidor
you know
just give them away go down to a bus
station hand them out to people say you
just you just had a baby or something
you know go old school
right and then just walk away
and once they're out of your house what
are you gonna do you just sit there like
I wanted one so bad today it had
a little window you know
my wife and daughter were having a a a
mommy daughter day they have all these
new things that they didn't have
when I was a kid
yesterday's and mommy daddy
I mean mommy daughter days and daddy
daughter days and all like they never
had that
like there was like oh and it's all just
marketing
like you know it's a good idea just have
a yes day with your kid like how the
is that a good idea
you know what I mean I mean what am I
teaching them about life and then it's
like no I'm going to reserve the right
to say no
dad can I buy this no you have enough
um we're having a yes day
um so anyway they were out doing that
not the yesterday they were having a
mommy daughter day
and
I put my son down for a nap and I had
like this you know he takes about 90
minute naps at this point
and I'm like
oh
I I could just go out on the porch right
now
you know
make myself a little
Double Espresso smoke a little shorty
you know and just sit out there looking
at the trees just having a good
time but I did not
have a cigar
and I was like I want a
cigar and I was like I could drive down
the street I can't I can't because I'm
the only one home and my son's here I
can't do that
so I did not end up smoking a cigar and
I'm happy that I didn't I wasn't happy
in the moment I also didn't even make
the espresso
Jesus Christ This is how boring my
life is right now you know what
and I wanted a cookie and I didn't have
one in the cupboard so I sat there and I
had a handful of peanuts
what you're listening to was a man who's
about ready to to officially hit his
mid-50s
which is cool by the way I did it you
know one of the highlights of my my week
was
and I reposted it
is
um
I love listening to people that know how
to tell stories and this is a random one
Jadakiss
all right the legendary rapper
uh told his story on a podcast
I retweeted it it's absolutely he's a
master storyteller
just the tone
with which he starts the story you think
it's going to be serious like it has
like this dramatic
sort of beginning and talking about a
friend of his and him saying hello to
all of his friends and all of that I
don't want to ruin the story so I'm not
going to go any further
and uh
where it goes and then how he wraps it
up
I was literally
going like I could listen to this guy
tell us tell stories for like
four hours there's no way
that that guy doesn't hold Court
everywhere he goes I mean
um if you get a chance I don't know what
the uh the pot I follow the podcast
whatever podcast it is they always have
great guests and they're always telling
you know all of these stories or
whatever
and all different kinds of stories but
this is the first one a nice quick
little clip
um and it was funny there's a friend of
mine
uh comedian
and this person's trying to learn how to
tell stories on stage
and which is to be honest with you
something I had
a difficult time with when I was
starting out because like when you start
out
you know you're sort of just doing like
setup punch show to jokes and stuff
and that's scary enough and you kind of
live in eight seconds
you know every eight seconds okay that
joke worked pretty good okay this one
worked better that one didn't work real
quick tell another one keep the crowd
keep the crowd right
and then the first time you go to tell a
story
it's like I feel like as far as a
comedian you've been you've been running
like 40 yard dashes that's what you did
and this is the first time you're
running like a one of the 600 meter or
whatever the hell it is just a longer
race and it just seems like forever
and you quickly lose
confidence in the thing kind of like
unravels so anyways I sent this
this Instagram clip
of of Jadakiss telling this story I was
just like if you just want to
I go watch this
I'll see you down the store and we're
going to talk I'm gonna break this down
on why this is so amazing and
all of the things you can use just by
watching him tell this story
um
and you can use this as like I don't
know
just keep watching this
that's just what I would say I don't
know sometimes I think about telling
stories either can do it or you can't
but there's definitely
um
I don't know this this
I don't even know how to you know it's
just comedy's such a weird thing
it's such a weird thing to try
to like talk to somebody and like
because you can't really teach somebody
how to do it you can just be like just
watch you gotta watch watch and then try
that's basically it so watch this clip
and then go try and if there's any com
young Comics or anybody listen to this
what I what I how I got over it was I
just
would be like
all right
say this is like a five minute story I'm
gonna commit
to the first 45 seconds of it tonight
yeah sorry I'm tired here I'm gonna
bail or whatever it's gonna when
it unravels and then tomorrow night I'll
I'll get through the first minute and
I'll just get comfortable with the first
minute of this story and then I'll have
some line to bail out of it and then you
just get more and more comfortable with
it
and uh
and then you got yourself a story then
you basically know how to do it I guess
that's what it is I I don't know
Jesus Christ
takes a weird bounce and he saves it
can't even read anymore can't see I
thought the guy the goalie's name was
Gallagher like the comedian rest his
soul that's what it isn't that's not
what it is
um
how about the Kraken coming out with
these killer uniforms
every time you think all the cool colors
are done
that was the weird thing about that that
um by the way there's no women
listening to this at this point
I've done nothing but talk sports other
than the Instagram clip
um
you know what I mean there's no women
listening to this like there's no women
supporting women's sports
[Laughter]
that on and showing the highlights
you know how about hey ladies hey
feminists how about a tip of the
cap to ESPN
for acting like you guys give a
um it's such a shame because I gotta
tell you there's some great female
sports out there obviously volleyball
there's no guys gonna say hey get this
volleyball game female volleyball game
off here right and then there's uh
women's softball
I mean the delivery alone in the picture
I can watch the picture all day
long
I don't know how they hit that ball and
I just love when one of them just
goes yard
um
all right now women's tennis is the
and uh
yeah there's three I mean guys only have
four we got baseball we own really like
three we have baseball basketball
and football are the big ones and then
then hockey is like the the the
the adopted kid you know
kid that just moved in one day
and we had to like uh get some bunk beds
oh all right am I gonna literally fall
asleep on my own podcast I'm so
emotionally drained from that
seven game of a series
um
I'll tell you what though
guess what I'm wearing tomorrow when I
walk out the door
my Bruins zip up I don't give a I'm
a big believer in that you still fly the
colors
you still fly the colors and you know
people are going to give you
let me what if my King's gonna I
mean La fan gonna give me
you guys didn't get out of the first
round either do you even know
that you didn't get out of the first
round even paying attention oh Bill
you're gonna lash out at Kings
fans is that what you're gonna do
uh yeah that's kind of what I am going
to do all right let's let's uh let's do
something here let's do this right here
um we gotta do the reads here we gotta
do the reeds
live reads and a show announcement all
right new show added
oh I'll be in Edmonton Alberta at
Kingsman Park on Sunday July 16th gee I
wonder if the Stanley Cup will be around
by then you know someone will have won
it God knows it won't be my team
um
you know what first the line at
that Super Mario ride two hours
and 40 minutes for a three minute
ride I feel like that's what
just happened to me as a hockey fan
uh
shout out to David craigie and Patrice
Bergeron I I got a bad feeling that was
the last game that they're gonna play
with us what a shame
incredible careers Stanley Cup champions
can't ever take that away from them um
oh this is my one pause that I'm taking
away last time we up this bad in
the playoffs playoffs was 2010. we were
up three games to none
and crazy got hurt and then Eric gagne
came back for the Flyers and I don't
know what the we lost four in a row
and I was just like what the and
um I remember watching game seven in
Boston I was
some bar
it was brutal and then the very next
year we won it so who knows who knows I
don't know how we do that without crazy
and Bergeron
but we will try all right uh local okay
so anyways I didn't read this whole
thing
uh new show added Edmonton Alberta at
Kinsman Park Sunday July 16th local and
artists pre-sales Wednesday
May 3rd at 9 00 A.M
Pacific time with the code Burr bur it
goes on sale Friday May 5th Cinco de
Mayo at 9 00 a.m Pacific
um
May 5th is also club soda Kenny's
birthday so please wish him a happy
birthday if you can
he's a great man all right and funny as
hell all right policy genius everybody
look who it is it's all policy genius
you know if you have a family like I do
you know how much your loved ones depend
on you in a worst case scenario you
wouldn't want them to worry about money
would you
well I wouldn't a good life insurance
plan can give you peace of mind that if
something happens to you your family
will have a safety net to cover mortgage
payments
College costs are other expenses so they
can get back on their feet and focus on
what's most important policy genius was
built to modernize the life insurance
industry
their technology makes it easy to
compare life insurance quotes from
America's Top insurers in just a few
clicks to find you the lowest price
now then with policy genius you can find
life insurance policies that start at
just 25 dollars per month
for one million dollars of coverage I
got a feeling the Avalanche trucker to
score another goal here they're starting
to get that look on their face uh in as
little as a week sorry some option
some options offer coverage in as little
as a week and avoid unnecessary medical
exams
what
how the are they going to give you
life insurance without a medical exam
maybe if you're young I guess I don't
know
policy genius has licensed agents who
can help you find the best fit for your
needs there's no added fees and your
personal details are private no wonder
they have thousands of five star reviews
on Google and trustpilot your loved ones
deserve a financial safety net you
deserve a smarter way to find and buy it
head to policy genius or click the link
in the description to get your free life
insurance quotes and see how much you
could save that's
policygenius.com p-o-l-i
c-y-g-e-n-i-u-s-p-o-l-i-c-y-g-n-i-u-s.com
it's really amazing how many of these
companies
is the exact same as that song uh
what is that name of that song
m-i-s-s-i-s it used to be so hard to
spell it used to make me cry but miss
that was like a hit song Back Then
you know
you didn't have to sing about you
could just spell the name of a state how
easy was it to write a hit song
Back Then
probably not easy you know it never was
how the would you how would you
even have a hit song before radio
is that Vanilla Ice
is that Vanilla Ice I'm gonna be really
happy if it is
wait a minute
Twisted Tea original was that there was
a guy in the Jeep Vanilla Ice
I don't know
anyway it's a bunch of people on a beach
with a DJ
yeah cause why would you want to listen
to the ocean
and actually taking this the Serenity
and listen to your kids when you could
have a guy with a laptop and a
AC DC Marshall stack blasting music into
your ear
you know you know what this beach is
missing right now uh a a a drum
and bass version of a Depeche Mode song
I don't know anything about either one
the band or
drum and bass I don't know what it is
it's just like I thought we would you
know
can't just go to the beach we gotta
create a Vibe I thought the beach was a
Vibe nah man nah
you got it yo you just gotta feel like
you know you're getting bottle service
anywhere you go
I told you a few months ago I was out to
dinner with my wife at a really nice
sushi restaurant I had to break
out my earplugs
you know like I was saying Kip Winger
and the Fellas
um what was the name of that dear
guitarist man that guy was a beast in
Winger
uh what the was his name
sometimes I feel like that's why they
got so much was the names in the
band
the names in the it was just
Reb it was kick Kip Winger red Beach Rod
morgenstein so you got Kip red and Ron
how the did he miss that
says the guy who could barely lift the
puck off the ice Jesus Christ I would
have buried that top shelf dude
on the Seattle Kraken Really
Gonna Knock off the defending well if
they do you're welcome Colorado because
no one's going to be talking about you
the only media was talking about us
um oh
no
oh no come on wind it up wind it up
I want overtime
oh I see what's cracking it doing
they're just clogging up the neutral
zone they got three guys back at the
Blue Line
what you want to do is you want to keep
them on the perimeter and then what what
the Avalanche want to do is try to get
some traffic in front of the goaltender
you see what he's doing here he's not
getting a clean shot at this he's not
going to clean look at yes we get it you
say this every game
oh now now I'm I'm yelling at random
analysts this is how upset I am
I'll tell you what is amazing is in my
refrigerator
yeah this is this new where you
just sort of back up back up back up
what the happened to hitting the
guy with the puck
you just sort of like get in the way of
them
you know
it's like a medium-sized dog
when you come home you're trying to get
up the stairs but it's happy to see and
you're like you get the out of the
way that's like it's that level
there's a little bit of a hit
all right everybody's standing around
now they're bringing it up the ice again
the fenceman's backing up people get
behind it's just it's the uh yeah there
you go he's in the corner nobody
hits him
I don't know it's a different game
they're all different games built guess
what I have in my room in my reefer
in my speaking of reefer in my
refrigerator somebody gave me these dude
and I highly highly
no pun intended recommend these
it's called This is a free advertisement
here it says Not Your Father's Root Beer
oh these aren't going to be twist-offs
are they
these will definitely not be twist offs
because there's weed in it
now I gotta do the old
do I got the thing here
[Music]
it used to be so I'm gonna rip my
finger open if I do that I don't
have a bottle opener I know I do I must
I must I want to drink some root
beer that has a little bit of weed in it
you kids have no idea how lucky you are
you know back in the day if you wanted
some goddamn reefer you had to
get in the back of a Ford Pinto
the gas tank about to be ignited
hang on let me open this thing
oh
he was able to do it will you look at
that that really surprised me
still got those skills
ah
you know what's funny is it doesn't
quite taste like root beer but you know
it is root beer
it tastes like somebody put some weed in
your root beer
time to be alive you know people sit
there
and they talk about how this goddamn
country is going to hell in a hand
basket what's going on in the world and
blah blah blah blah blah let me tell you
something the world has always
been up because God has been in a
hammock since he made the place
all right he doesn't give a
okay and he makes mouth breathing morons
that listen to sociopaths that attack
innocent people that's essentially human
behavior on a global level but in the
meantime
he makes every once in a while he makes
a good that puts weed in
root beer
okay now let me tell you I know there's
a lot of problems out there
you know
but you know the fact that there is weed
in root beer you can drink root beer and
get high after your team
blows it in the first goddamn round
you know I mean I I don't think it's
that bad
you know I was thinking about getting a
karaoke machine
you know just for the family
have a good time you know make absolute
fools of ourselves
I just think it's a good thing for like
kids to like not be self-conscious about
getting up in front of a group of people
um
because that really affects your life
you know
like uh
just like not giving a in a good
way
like not to the point if you're hurting
people but just be like
you just you just kind of get to that
point you know like Pete Rose
he didn't give a
I'm managing this team and I'm betting
on it
you know I mean how far ahead of his
time was he
that guy was bet MGM
30 years before bed MGM
and all of these
gambling websites
he was doing that before all of them
I like how he was always guessing
fastball you've been talking about hit I
love listening to Pete Rose talk about
hitting
he was saying I I just always guess
fastball
you know
he goes because that's going to be his
fastest pitch so if anything else comes
I can adjust to it
you know and he goes never never adjust
your swing your swing is how you got to
the show all right choke up on the bat
move forward move back in the batter's
box but you don't with your swing
that's what got you here
when he said it I was just like Jesus
that sounds really obvious
I wonder why I never thought that oh
that's right I'm dumb I drink root beer
with weed in it
um
oh shout out to that guy right behind
the bench with the old Quebec nordiques
Jersey
does have Joe sakix number on it you
know what he should he should have
who's in one of the one of the
Stassney Brothers
Michelle Goulet
you know a Dale Hunter
there's a good one Jesus Christ Dale
hunter that there was a guy
there was a guy that just didn't skate
around with you he had to know where the
hell that guy was
um he had a brother too and one time
they actually grabbed me oh
oh my God there's three minutes left
there's three minutes left
and the exciting
Colorado Avalanche with the next Bobby
Orr and Nathan McKinnon are going to get
knocked out
by the Seattle crapping
the Kraken what is that plankton
is that another bird oh a two-on-one
save
all right here's one for all you hockey
fans out there who's the greatest
goaltender you ever saw
all right
for me without a doubt and I you know I
was talking to Joe bartnick about this
Patrick Wah
I still think is the is you know I never
saw Ken Dryden but I would say that's
the greatest goaltender of all time
um
100 I don't give a about whoever
played uh
you know during like I don't Martin
Brody is a hard one because I feel like
he gets punished by the the error that
he played in at least in my head clutch
and grab dump you know dump and Chase
and he could just skate back and stop it
you could skate way out stop it and
flick it back down the ice
it was such a horrible period in
hockey Jesus Christ
I mean I I get to the point I was almost
done with the game so it's it's
incredible what they what they did for
the game my brochure is definitely top
five but I still think Patrick was
better
um
anyway uh all right let's get to some
reads here for this week Jesus Christ we
lost
can't believe it uh
anyway
um old guy in suburbs
bill there's an old guy who drives
around town every day smoking a cigar in
his Lincoln Continental uh
I mean a guy he gets life he goes he's
not some super classy guy but he's not a
bum either he's just a middle of the
road dude who seems super happy why
wouldn't you be
oh hit the post
how the do they see that it doesn't
go in that quickly
Jesus Christ
um
yeah why wouldn't he be happy
there is something to be said for those
people that like maybe just smokes one a
day and he's fine
I don't know
um all right what do I got here uh
sorry I'm trying to watch this the end
of this game to to
uh he pulls up to spots and never really
gets out of his car he'll stop by the
car wash or gas station in town and just
chat out his window with friends he'll
grab coffee and occasionally lean on his
car but it's mostly cruising
in a members only jacket
sounds like something you'd want to do
are you kidding me
I mean if they made a Netflix series
about that guy or people like that
I got it here's the Netflix series you
follow that guy around
him just enjoying his life with a
members only jacket a probably
you know average price cigar in his
Lincoln Continental happy as hell and
you call this series he gets it
foreign
you know that seems like somebody like
Oprah remember when Oprah was obsessed
on trying to figure out how to be happy
and she was like trying to teach all of
us how to be happy but you really knew
secretly it was also for her which made
it a little sad and funny if you
up like me
like I do remember one time she did this
thing I I might be wrong on this one
which I'm wrong about a lot of but
I remember one time she did this
thing
and she was talking about the happiest
places on Earth
and she one of the places she went to
was Dubai and she was Dubai she went to
Dubai right
and she was talking about how
happy everybody was there and they don't
even pay any taxes they all this stuff
they don't pay any taxes it's like Jesus
Christ
what are you doing here Oprah you know
it comes from somewhere well it turns
out they have slave labor there
I found that out when I went to uh
I think for people in India told me that
they said neither go to India or like
Pakistan and they promised these poor
people work in a better life and when
they go to Dubai the first thing they do
is they confiscate their passport and
then they enslave them and the number
one cause of death for those people that
go there and they have to build all
those buildings is suicide
uh this is like one of the happiest
places ever I swear to God I think she
said Dubai because I remember I was
watching it with my lovely wife and she
was getting annoyed with me and I was
going like that's not a happy place just
like you know so she's like can't you
just shut up and let me enjoy a
show I was like all right fair enough
fair enough I get it
this is your game seven evidently
um
oh we fed on It come on put the biscuit
in the basket oh it's a race to the
end I sing gotta love no touch icing
one of the stupidest things ever
was racing down to the boards so you
could break your ankle or your
leg all right friend didn't
invite me to fake wedding
all right I swear to God if this is
written by a man
I might just tap out if this is written
by a woman you know what else is new
friend didn't invite me to a fake
wedding so what did you do high five
them
all right dear Billy bridegroom
this person did you in advance solid
anyway I need your advice a close friend
of mine recently got married to a girl
from the U.S
we're from Wales
uh my buddy told me that they're having
two weddings this first one was just so
his partner could stay in the country
and the real wedding
will be later in the year
I have been invited to the air quote
real wedding
and was told that no friends were
invited to the first one only a few
immediate family members oh my God for
the life of me I don't
understand why people give a
whether or not they're invited to a
wedding
and why
everybody who isn't getting married
makes the wedding all about them
can you have some empathy for the two
people getting married all the
all the fights all the planning
all the money they have to go through if
they don't want to invite you who gives
a God bless them
they did you a solid
anyway who the wants to go to a
wedding nobody
or women women want to go to weddings I
don't know
my wife you know we watch the
Real Housewives of New Jersey that Joe
and Melissa guy they're freaking
out because you know they're not getting
invited to like to to the the
the guy's sister's second wedding
okay you went to the first one who gives
a
I went to the first Patriots
Super Bowl victory I never went to any
of the other ones you know what I'm good
I saw the first one that's the best one
that's the best one the second one is
you know you just don't want to die
alone
anyways
turns out that three of our mutual
friends were actually in attendance at
this fake wedding oh as well as the
party they had the same weekend this
upset me because I never would have
excluded this guy if I was the one
getting married
we've been good friends for 15 years or
so I thought
I would consider him a closer friend if
he doesn't invite me to his fake
ass wedding
um I haven't talked to him since and I
don't know what to do
should I ask for an explanation or
should I just let it go and not let it
ruin our friendship after all I've been
invited to the real wedding would love
to hear your thoughts on this situation
thanks and go
I can't read
ffwcio yourself
oh that's Welsh yeah dude you
gotta you know at some point the
Seattle crack can just beat the
goddamn Colorado Avalanche are you
kidding me two to one
congratulations to the Seattle Kraken
wow how the mighty are falling
um yeah dude you gotta let your balls
drop at some point and just are
you really gonna do this I mean you're
acting like a chick here what the
are we doing
you know first of all if you if you're
ever upset with somebody about something
go talk to him about it all
right the last thing you do is like and
a gun I'm not talking to you do
you know why I know that because I used
to do that for the first 54 and a half
years of my life not not that long but I
used to do that now my deal is I have
problem with somebody I talk to
them
I don't go around talking about
people I don't go you know what
this guy did it's just like well
go talk to that guy what is that what he
did well why are you talking to me about
it
so
um
foreign
yeah I just think like
whatever his reason is
I got to be honest with you the fact
that you're making this big a deal out
of it I kind of understand why I didn't
invite you maybe you need to be a little
more chill
and stop acting like a lady
um I would 100 get over it and I would
have a great time at his wedding I would
say congratulations I would get him a
nice gift and I would leave it
at that like I mean
if you don't
and people ask you why you the
friendship ended you're gonna have to
tell this story
okay so my friend was getting married
and there's like two weddings and one
wasn't the real one one was the fake one
but was uh you know I was invited to the
real one but then I found out three of
friends were invited to the Franklin I
mean
that's like you know when you tell that
story somebody's gonna be like just
staring into their beer going like is
this like did you steal this story
from a woman this is something a woman
gets upset about all right so you know
I don't know much about the Welsh people
but I feel like you're you're really not
representing them well
all right but God damn it
you represent the welshinians
correctly
I would get over it is what I would do
and I would just go have a good
time and that's it all right
I will leave it at that all right drunk
slapped by cow
by a cow's tail or by a fat woman what
are we talking about here dear Billy
Bullocks all my girlfriend's house at my
girlfriend's housewarming party last
Friday her housemate invited a friend
that was so woke
that she sounds like a caricature
all right well anytime you guys use the
term woke you got to Define it because
everybody has a different definition of
it now that
uh White culture took the word and made
it mean something completely different
so now what is that she's just overly
sensitive
about
which is not what it initially meant
um anyway she is studying a PhD in
gender studies
shock she's quite overweight shock and
her attitude to me and the male friends
I brought to the party was condescending
from the start
yeah I mean she's getting that
poured in her head every day
I mean I would love to see gender
studies and how
sexist it is in the other
direction you got to watch out for
liberals man
you know I mean conservatives are easy
to see
you know they're coming down they're
burning across they're screaming slurs
and the Liberals the way they do it
you know they hide behind you know
they're black or their gay friend
um all right
sorry I'm around here maybe it's
the weed and the root beer it doesn't
work that fast people
um and her attitude to me okay
nevertheless my girlfriend and I are
going to be spending a lot of time in
this house why
so I did not react or get put off by the
condescending tone to me or my friends
I asked her about her PhD and told her
that it sounded interesting
all right well that's a mistake
why would you do that you've completely
misrepresented yourself and you've
actually
just pumped her ego
I love these hockey fans that just hang
out like their dog just died yeah okay a
game ended you know what I mean you're
disappointed maybe they're just waiting
for the traffic that's a beautiful
facility huh
everybody that was coming down the
escalator is going to be dead by the
time they're 60. the people that took
the stairs will live to be 65.
um
sorry I was just doing the quick math
there
okay
anyway then she started insulting my
friends my friends responded with some
banter of their own which made me laugh
this woke cow saw me laughing at my
friend's joke
with a full bowl of vodka in my hands
and she smacked the bowl into my chin
you're drinking vodka out of a bowl
must have been some cheap huh
covering me in vodka not to mention
presenting a bit of danger with the
glass hitting me in the face I have a
very bad temper as the shape and I work
hard on it I have some issues with the
police in the past for violence oh boy
so all my friends expected me to see red
and smack this
to the suffragette
let's forget era oh my God that's
hilarious but I didn't and I avoided it
by walking away my issue is I keep
picturing it in my mind when I try to
sleep or just in the middle of the day
oh yeah
I know you have something similar so I
was hoping you might have a solution for
the murderous thoughts in my mind
dude I gotta tell you something right
now I can't even tell you the
empathy that I have for you right now
um
I know what it's like to have somebody
with you that you that you you
the system defends
you know what I mean and you can't hit
them because it's just it's just gonna
be a loss for you
you know it's just one of those deals so
um anyway go yourself in the ass
with a Sandy red dildo you
Ginger tainted
I gotta feel like most of that's the
anger in that last thing was uh
geared towards uh the woke fatty anyway
P.S the fact that you've got a family
has actually helped me believe I could
be able to have one someday too so thank
you and best wishes that's such
it's hilarious that you then
finished on something that nice
um
all right that that is
so up I wait housewarming okay
my girlfriend and I are gonna be
spending a lot of time in this house
um
all right
here's the number one thing uh
if she keeps going around doing that
someone is gonna punch her in the face
just let it be somebody else
okay
um
I'm not gonna lie to you you know when
people say hey don't worry about someday
they'll get theirs a lot of times they
don't
they don't and they just surround
themselves with weak people that
put up with like that all right you
don't have to put up with like that
so when you can tell your girlfriend
is unknown under no was it no uncertain
terms
I I'm trying to think if there's any
expression that I actually
100 percent know how to say
um
I would just say we're not going back to
that house
no I got you know if you know it's
something better
is that you tell your girlfriend that
that fatty owes you an apology
and that you're considering going to the
cops
to press charges for assault
you know if you do you really want to do
that though do you want to get it to
that point
um
I don't know like what can you do
what can you do there's nothing you can
do the the society protects a fat
it just does it's just one of those
things and all you can do is just
somehow
just you just got to work on your own
life
and just be glad that somebody else
the ballist man
that's gonna crawl on top of her every
night is just like
I mean just be happy it's not you
that's all I can say I mean that's just
it's it's ridiculous and I've
said this
a million times that
women should respect the fact that a
man's not going to hit him rather than
take advantage of it that is just
I mean who's Ken who sir if I did that
to you uh I would be at the
dentist right now
and no one would give a they would
all be saying to me well what the
did you think was going to happen did
you really think you're going to smack a
glass bowl into his face
with his alcohol in it I still
understand how vodka is in a bowl
um
anyway
I have found uh
uh I've tried meditation and stuff like
that but like
you really have to work on it's it's a
skill
is when stuff like that happens
letting go of it and I actually that
happened to me
recently and I forget what I did
you know
sometimes now when people come at me I
just go like you know what this is just
all part of the
the deal if I'm gonna do what it is that
I do it's not all going to be Sunshine
that I'm gonna have to deal with certain
people in it
the you gonna do and I just sort of
move on
you know it's like well I could fixate
on that or I can just continue
I don't know go just go do something fun
go to a game or some like that but
I I I would tell you like I can't even
tell you how much empathy I have for you
like of being in a situation like that
where someone just so clearly you know
crosses a line like that
and nobody says anything and then if you
do something that you're wrong
is uh
that's a tough one so uh but the upside
is is you just tell your girlfriend that
I'm that that's that's that's a wrap
I'm not going over there
um
you know what sucks is even if you saw
her
and he just said hey hey Fatso can I
talk to you for a second do you realize
how lucky you are
that you're not a guy because I would
have beat the out of you
and I would have smash that
bowl over your head and I would have
picked up the shards and I would have
stuck it right in your gut and watched
you die slowly
if you don't have a temper you don't
understand these thoughts
but the thing is you can't say that to
her because then you're threatening her
there's really there's nothing you can
do
other than just tell the story
to your friends laugh about it and then
go to the gym and try to get it out of
you but uh I wouldn't fight with your
girlfriend about it
I would just get yourself into a really
Zen mindset and just say honey
is a deal uh what that happened to me
was
unbelievably humiliating
um the level of anger that I have
towards that person and the fact that
I'm not allowed to do anything because
she's a woman which is the reason why
she went up and did that to me
because she knew she could get away with
it
um I don't ever want to be around that
person again
and it's just a non-negotiable
and then I gotta be honest with you if
your girlfriend's gonna be hanging
around her too then what the does
what is she doing
you know what I mean
like what if some girl went up and did
that to her
and then you're still hanging out with
that girl that did it that doesn't make
any sense
but um I I wouldn't don't get angry with
your girlfriend just say like this is
how it is and then if she doesn't want
to do it
that I don't know then you just have a
calm conversation of like ah you know I
think I kind of want to spend the rest
of my life with a person that like
doesn't want to hang out with somebody
who just smashed a glass bowl on
my face
is that Henrik Lundqvist
is he
that's Anson Carter
anyway let me move on sorry
um movie sorry I'm still got the TV on I
got the analysts on right now all right
movie recommendation
Los Angeles plays itself
now what is that that sounds uh
that sounds interesting let's see Los
Angeles plays it said hey Bill have you
ever heard this documentary it's
incredible I just stumbled upon it it
examines all the way ways Los Angeles
impacts its character on film and
culture through architecture stereotypes
Etc highly recommended tons of cool
footage and insight
examines all the ways Los Angeles
imparts its character on film
and I could look up in parts
why is that because we'll try to make
Brentwood look like Vancouver
um I don't know anyway that is the
podcast everybody uh thank you so much
for listening
ah
tough tough loss what are you
gonna do I still love the Bruins
congratulations
um to the Panthers and I'm just going to
enjoy the hell out of watching that
Panthers leaf series uh oh wait the
Rangers and Devils out of game
seven oh that's tomorrow
I'm gonna watch that
I'm just gonna watch that oh I can't
even drink root beer with weed in it
because then I'm gonna be
I'm gonna be off by the way if we
learned anything you know if your team
loses a game seven of a series they
should have won
uh I I highly recommend Not Your
Father's Root Beer and for that poor
gentleman
you know what I mean dude I got an idea
I got an idea
holy every once in a while I have
an idea
oh it's too diabolical but I gotta tell
you
just start sending her desserts
I don't know how to do it
or how how to get but you know she's
gonna eat them you just gotta
one of your punishment
rather than you know doing the normal
what is if you just try to make her
like 50 pounds fatter is there a law
against that I feel like this is like
something if you made somebody morbidly
obese because they threw a drink in your
face
oh dude wait a minute maybe that's what
you do maybe you don't say anything your
girlfriend
and what you do is you just buy a
ridiculous amount of sweets
every time you go over there and you
just leave them behind knowing that
she's gonna house him the second
everybody walks out of there
right and I mean like toxic
like Cinnabon
anything from Entenmann's you know just
that
like that old people used to eat
when I was a kid and they'd just be dead
it just like dude when I was a kid
people died
you know people live now man they live
for a long time and they live quality
lives people were I mean
when you were 50 you were like you had
one foot in the grave the
was over
maybe that's what you do
you know and don't oh you know what
don't buy
oh my god dude
don't buy desserts go to the best
cupcake place there just say Hey listen
I'm sorry I laughed at you the other day
feed your ego say Hey you know maybe I
should take one of those women's studies
courses
and you give her the cupcakes right and
you just listen to our
her reverse sexist as
you watch her eating these
things and then you just keep going over
there and then she'll actually start to
love you
all right
and then when she gets to her fattest
when she can't get out of the chair
that's when you walk up to her just too
diabolical okay
I mean there's so many different ways to
do it there's a way that you could just
start sending them to her job
saying she has a secret admirer no
that's too mean it's just all too mean
you know what you know what all this
is that I'm
this is all Vengeance I don't like
vengeance is the darkest of all
human uh emotions I feel
even more show than what are the seven
deadly sins
like one of them it's it's uh
what's the uh the anger one
what's the word they use for that let's
see there was there was uh
wrath become Wrath
the end of seven I remember that
um
does venge is Vengeance tied in with
Wrath
is Vengeance like wrath adjacent I don't
know
um
I would go over that would bring a big
chocolate a yellow cake with
chocolate frosting
you know
and I'd cut her a big slice and
Bae sorry about that
and in your head you're just like that's
right get fatter die quicker
hahaha
all right I'm sorry some of that had to
do with the fact that my team
won 65 games and just lost in the first
round
the other part really was came from an
empathetic place all right that's it go
yourselves I'll check in on you on
Thursday